31 City US and Canada tour oh my guy
yeah so you guys okay yeah my guy is the
thing to actually like we hirin thing
like in rap world people were like oh i
see i see those new shoes my guy it's
like it's like a hot sling right oh
really my guy yeah my guy is a thing
even saying that for years
that's my I started and it's an old
thing that 31 cities so you you do
one-nighters in the cities yeah there's
only a couple of days that we have off
after a show let me ask you this is do
you take a plane to every gay go you
take a book we're taking it and this
it's like a sprinter van I can't afford
a bus yet yeah but that's like the level
how many seats do you play I mean how
many people come to your shows right now
I would say it's anywhere well we have a
couple cities that's like a thousand two
hundred Wow but uh usually right now the
average right now is probably three to
seven hundred that's great yeah it's a
lot that's that doesn't mean all the
cities are selling well but I mean
there's a lot of cities I do well but I
I wanted to add a lot of new cities on
this run where I kind of test it out so
well I mean also did let me say this so
I have been in certain markets yeah
where I don't do well at first right you
know though the club will go yeah we we
only sold 150 200 tickets a show and
then you get you can get depressed but I
know this for a fact
afterwards probably eighty ninety
percent of the time the club owner or
whoever will go we can build here though
because your shows were good right right
if the shows are good then it doesn't
matter what the numbers are in the
beginning because then when you come
back you'll double that is it the words
word-of-mouth spreading or what is it
exactly for my shows I don't know what
your show is like but my show is this is
is that holy [ __ ] people go we didn't
think you were gonna be that funny
okay we didn't think that you were gonna
do this specific thing that I do right
and they go I gotta bring my friend Joe
Joe next time right and so the next time
they bring Joe but everyone brings
somebody
right right and then you know and then
you go back to fifth or sixth time and
it's you doing guaranteed business right
it takes a long time but that's
old-school showbiz and that's what I
like about you going on this tour I'm
still on that grind man it's not no it's
this is gonna be forever for you yeah
okay I hope so no it is not no you know
what it is here's the thing you know
I've been you know a lot of times I get
I got to go to El Paso this weekend yeah
I got it all my route to El Paso you're
right so I'm playing I'll pass so this
weekend and I don't know what it's gonna
I haven't been there in 20 years almost
but you know what I'm excited about it
because I haven't been there a long time
I don't know what's gonna happen and
also I can show the people that live
there that I'm legit too and I'm gonna
show them what I do and my you know
point of view the way I do it and so I'm
excited and if if there's only 50 people
the show well yeah I think a lot of has
to do with a show coming out and I don't
really have to rely on it but my point
is is the whole thing I mean you know
some of those cities never get [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying so to me that's the
cool thing that you actually included
them you know they're like these kids
sometimes can't ever go like they can't
drive 3-4 hours to the next city you
know what quality sure you know what he
says
good you can always make a living I go
how you guys look where I'm playing but
don't get dunk Canada Oh some see you
Berta right right because I'm the only
thing that's been there for five years
dead oh [ __ ] and so when he shows up at
that holiday in the whole city comes
it's a whole ban point though is is that
you know do you think he gives a [ __ ]
the difference between Chicago and that
right right you go to Chicago I mean I I
went to Philadelphia once I showed up on
my first show I'm not even kidding you
at the helium there was 20 people there
on a Friday and I go what the [ __ ]
because I know but right across the
street of Chapelle
oh well I'm gonna fire my agent that
happened driving in LA you know my Elio
is slower than a lot of other shows
right because they have so much [ __ ]
going on every week yeah well they're
spoiled you know what I mean so it's
good to go to these smaller towns and to
show them you know and give them
entertainment everyone deserves to get
entertained for sure anyway you were a
very uh pleasurable guest I really
really enjoyed you I really did
immensely and um I've had many people on
the show and you were probably one of my
biggest surprises oh thank you man I
just don't I don't really I'm not no no
I'm being real I really enjoyed it yeah
I really enjoyed you know I think it
genuinely yeah not being real game
you're playing right now literally what
I mean what I was trying to mean he says
I legitimately mean there's no sarcasm
oh so I was saying that you were a
really really good guest all right all
right
[Music]